it sounds like that was your launcher
then for maybe getting up in the morning
and going somewhere that maybe was a
horrible but it just wasn't what your
passion was was what can I learn from
this yes exactly and what about times
when people say I just can't do this
anymore how do you know your breaking
point you said there were times when you
did have to walk away I think that
before you walk away from something you
wrestle with it a long time and you know
you always have that moment where you
sit quietly and talk to yourself and you
say what am I giving up if I leave what
am i gaining if I stay what am i gaining
if I leave and you make your decision
and sometimes life steps in and tells
you that it's time for you to go
something happens you know in your life
that says oh okay I'm not supposed to be
doing this anymore and so you just kind
of listen to it as you go along would
you give yourself a time period let's
say you accepted something that again
wasn't horrible but it wasn't where you
wanted to be and you say okay I can do
this for you and that's never worked for
me I don't know why I know other people
say in three years I want to be here and
I when I say that it's like oh my god I
put a pressure on myself that I can't
possibly deal with oh it's almost like I
have to live an organically day to day
and say where am I today on this you
know what do I want to be doing do i do
I still want to do this is this you know
where i want to be so it's not like i
say in a year I want to be doing this or
that and maybe that's not a good thing
maybe that's why it takes me so long to
do everything I mean eight years on a
movie is a long time but it it's more
organic for me it's the way I work
you